the entrepreneurs who I think build
things that last for a long time keep
going because they care fundamentally
about the change that they're trying to
create in the world getting transparency
inside a company is really critical
there's this culture in Silicon Valley
that kind of makes startups seem
glamorous and I never really believed
that the motivations watch a top 10 with
belief nation
what's up elevation 7 I believe in you
and this channel is designed to be part
of your daily success routine so let's
get your motivation to attend and get
you believing in you grab a snack and
chill in today's lessons from a man who
went from being a college dropout who
started facebook from his dormitory room
at Harvard to becoming the world's
youngest billionaire at 23 years old and
now having a net worth of over 55
billion dollars he's Mark Zuckerberg and
here's my take on his top 10 rules to
success volume 3 enjoy also if you want
to know what Mark Zuckerberg and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence to
link to join is in the description below
the biggest risk you can take is not
taking any risk
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one create change to me entrepreneurship
is about creating change not just
creating companies and you know the most
effective entrepreneurs that who I've
met it care deeply about some mission
and some change that they're trying to
create and often they don't even start
because they're trying to create a
company
all right and you know that's how I
think about you know my connection to to
all of us here is you know I was getting
started I am and I want it I care deeply
about giving everyone a voice right and
giving people the tools to share
everything that they cared about and
bring a community together and you know
it started small and in one university
and I didn't think it was gonna be a
company at the time as a matter of fact
I was pretty convinced that at some
point someone would build something like
this for the world but you know I
thought that that would be some other
company that you know already had
thousands of Engineers and was used to
building stuff for hundreds of millions
of people around the world and you know
what ended up happening was you know
that no one built it right so we just
kind of kept on going right I mean
people said it each step along the way
you know what you're doing alright maybe
college students like it but no one else
is gonna like it and you know there's
not gonna be any money in doing this so
all right so you only really do it if
you care all right if you're passionate
about doing it and then it started
growing and people said it would be a
fad and it would never be a good
business but you know you keep going
because you care not because you're
you're trying to create a business and
you know then there's the shift in
mobile where people thought that you
know it wouldn't be a sustainable
business and you know it through each of
these things you the entrepreneurs who I
think build things that last for a long
time keep going because they care
fundamentally about the change that
they're trying to create in the world
and they're not in it just to build a
company rule number two care more Steve
Jobs cared a little bit too much about
how perfect the edges of some polygons
were right um
what is it that you care too much about
connecting everyone no seriously if you
think about I mean it's like this
aesthetic sense of the world that I have
is that you can communities of people
can channel their energy to do great
things and having connections between
people is the infrastructure for the
world to do that and you know that's why
it each step along the way when there
was always all this uncertainty about
you know whether it would be profitable
or whether it would make sense or be
good or whatever to do these thing this
we always were doing it because we just
cared more and I mean to this day I mean
you could you could say that that was a
startup thing but it isn't because I
mean now we're we're here and we connect
more than a billion people but I mean I
we're pouring tons of money and
resources into connecting people who
can't even afford internet access right
so I mean that's like there's no way
that that's gonna be profitable in the
near-term or medium-term but we're doing
it because we think it's the right thing
to do and over the long term I do think
that there's something there and it's
gonna be fundamentally important for the
world and maybe we'll get rewarded maybe
not but we just really care rule number
three start small I made a very simple
focus and idea
the goal wasn't to make a huge community
site is to make something where you
could type in someone's name and find
out a bunch of information about them I
took a few days and just threw together
Facebook and launched it on February 4th
2004 it was just me working on at that
time but at that point my roommate
Dustin who haven't had much computer
programming experience at all I was like
you know I can help you expand and I'm
like that's cool dude but you don't have
a program so he's like no no it's not an
issue and he went home one weekend to
block the book crawl for dummies came
back was like I'm ready and then we
start getting emails from people at a
bunch of other schools asking if we
could launch Facebook's there in the
last tech bubble most websites will run
using these really expensive machines
which made it that you had to basically
go and raise money before you could do
anything
we ran the site originally for $85 a
month renting computers for the first
three months were you ever dead
I know and dad $160 rule number four be
transparent getting a transparency
inside a company is really critical but
if the people running the company
don't have a sense of what all of the
people around the company are worried
about then you're not gonna be able to
run the company as best as possible and
so that's why I do think it's like every
week I run a an open QA and it's that
way anyone can come and ask me any
question but it's not only that we try
to make it so that we encourage people
to ask the hardest possible questions we
create a poll in advance and people can
submit questions and people can vote on
them and they can do that anonymously so
that way I will make sure every week
that I know what the top issues are that
people are worried about inside the
company ends that I can address that and
we certainly have a pretty flat
management culture we're not generally
very hierarchical you know I talked to a
lot of my product managers and engineers
and just go through many layers of
management because I want to hear what's
going on and that's just that's how we
try to operate the company and I think
that's very important number five do
good I kind of think about what we're
doing today I'm very similarly to how I
thought about where we were at the
beginning you know it's you know I get
people all the time who come to me and
say all right well you're investing
billions of dollars in trying to put
Internet connectivity and in places
where you know we don't get paid for it
it's not something that will that will
make any money from for a very long
period of time if it works out but you
know it's this deep belief that you're
trying to make a change you're trying to
connect people in the world and I really
do believe that if you do something good
and if you help people out then
eventually some portion of that good
will come back to you and you may not
know upfront what it's gonna be but
that's just been the guiding principle
for me and the work that we've done rule
number six build a good team you know
companies are not about any one person
right it's really not about any two
people either they're there these
combinations of people and teams and I
think the ones that that work best are
when you have people who have different
strengths who complement each other and
I think a huge part of the success of
Facebook and our ability to grow the
community has been because of the
partnership that we've built and
and a number of other really special
people here who are on the the core
group who just each have different
skills and are very different and are
not afraid to to challenge each other
and bring their voice to the table and I
think that that's a special thing rule
number seven study success there's this
culture in Silicon Valley that kind of
makes startups in glamorous and I never
really believed that right I never had a
goal of starting a startup and my goal
when I realized that I had a company was
to get it to be a good company as
quickly as possible where I didn't kind
of get out of what you'd call they're
like risky startup phase where you are
just like constantly about to die and
where you can get to a point where you
can actually do some interesting things
and make make a lot of more interesting
bets and um so I don't know I I never
read a lot of the literature on this and
I mean maybe if I had then I wouldn't
made so many mistakes but I don't know
if like if learning for me is the right
way to go on this but I mean but it did
your model must have come from somewhere
though even if it was even if you it was
unintentional
right like were you influenced by Peter
Thiel rashon well yes by all these
people once I met them I actually I
hadn't really heard of Peter Thiel
before I'm yeah right yeah he was
massively influential on my thinking
right I mean I like a lot of the the
early lessons that I took on how to
think about strategy came from Peter and
Sean and I did pay a lot of attention
when I was growing up to Microsoft I
thought I mean I grew up you know using
you know Windows 3.1 and then Windows 95
and I just thought that those were like
the most unbelievable things and since
they are yeah they really were awesome
right well I don't know if you you meant
that positive positively but I did and
and I thought you know building this
ecosystem was really neat and that kind
of inspired me right in the way that
they built a platform I kind of thought
okay well maybe one day you know that
the tools that I'm building can be part
of a broader ecosystem as well Rula
brave take on the challenges Facebook is
a for-profit company why call it dot org
is this a non-profit is this charity you
know if we were primarily focused on
profits the the most reasonable thing
for us to do would be to really just
focus on the first billion people who
are using our products I mean the world
isn't set up equally and you know the
first billion people are using Facebook
have way more money than the rest of the
world combined so from a business
perspective it actually doesn't make a
huge amount of sense for us to put the
emphasis in this that we are right now
the reason why we're doing it is two
things one is mission I mean we're here
to help connect the world and we take
that really seriously and you know you
to some degree you can't really do that
if two-thirds of the world doesn't even
have access to the Internet so you know
we just turned 10 as a company and we
decided that in our next 10 years we
want to take on some really big
challenges in the world like helping
everyone get online and that's just an
important thing for for us and I think
for a lot of other internet companies
and for filling this mission overall
know over the long term I do think it
could be good for for our company as
well if you look at it in a 10 20 30
year time horizon because a lot of these
countries and economies will develop and
over time they will be important
rule number nine be proud of what you do
but if we've given the world a voice
look at what's happened in the last year
you've had elections in the last year's
elections manipulated hate speech that's
gone viral and turned offline it
certainly seems like this mission has
been accomplished in many ways and and
there's a whole new set of problems that
perhaps you guys didn't foresee and now
we're in a very complicated place where
there's not an easy solution yeah
there's these are complex issues that
you can't fix you manage them on an
ongoing basis but look do you think that
the world is better with everyone having
a voice and having the ability to
express their opinion and being able to
connect to who they want I don't think
we're going back to a world where there
were just a handful of gatekeepers who
got to control what ideas get expressed
and even if I think that even if we
could what I'm trying to make it so
we're not I mean that's why making it so
that we're building these independent
governance mechanisms and things like
that are really important and that's
that's work that I that I really care
about but I think that the world will
keep on moving in this direction people
will more people will keep on getting a
voice I think that that's good and and
and and I think there are certainly
going to be issues that we need to work
through
time but I think that while we are doing
that we can't lose sight of all of the
really positive things that are that are
happening here as well not just in terms
of communities and people being able to
to connect with with groups that are
really meaningful to them whether it's
around a disease or or community around
veterans that they wouldn't be able to
connect to otherwise but even if you
just think about the economic impact of
what we're doing you know we serve 80
million small businesses around the
world about half of them have told us
that they're hiring people because of
using our tools and that without
Facebook and the tools that we that we
provide and that they that their
business would be significantly smaller
and they wouldn't be hiring as many
people as they are so you know a study
came out the US economy added about four
and a half million jobs over the last
year if you just look at like what
people are telling us the small
businesses who use our tools we've
directly been able to contribute to
creating many more jobs than that across
the world so I think that this is the
power of giving people a voice giving
small businesses giving communities
giving everyone everywhere the ability
to connect with the people who who they
care about and get their opinion across
and giving everyday people the power
that previously only big companies would
have had so that's it the world is gonna
go more in that direction and I think by
and large that's a good thing so I'm
really proud of the work that we're
doing on this and we there are big
issues and I'm not trying to to say that
there aren't that we need to work
through but I do think that sometimes
you can you can get the flavor from a
lot of this from from some of the
coverage that that that's all there is
and and I don't think that that's right
either we need to make sure that we
address these these questions these are
really big and important things for the
future of our society in the future of
the internet but we also need to keep
pushing in the direction of empowering
more people because that's good and will
them retain the last one before a very
special bonus slip is has fine you kind
of need to remind yourself that you need
to focus and and try not to let stuff
bother you as much as possible but it is
gonna bother you because you're human
and and I was human I am human still but
put it but I was just referring to
myself in the past not that I was not
human one of the crazy things when you
do this live cute is someone were very
silly so we got one mark are the
allegations true that you're secretly a
lizard I don't have to go no on that I'm
not a lizard but you know keep the high
quality comments coming in please this
is surely on track to be a great live
Q&A if we if we continue getting stuff
it at that level of quality now the
bonus clip from Mark Zuckerberg on how
to constantly improve that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that
except for the three-point landing
questions time to move from just
watching a video to take heed shooting
your life for business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question for
wanna what big challenge are you taking
on number two who's successful you
commit to studying and number three what
small step can you take towards your
goals have you personally changed in any
capacity to be able to be better
equipped to handle facebook now rather
than the Facebook that you built in your
dorm room absolutely I mean I'm always
thinking about this stuff and I think
the biggest learning for me which I'm
too slow too is that you know when you
connect two and a half billion people
you're gonna see all the good that
they're capable of and an incredible
thing this but you're also going to have
all these people who just try to use
those tools to subvert the same ideals
that we care about and now you know
we're taking that line this towards
everything that we're doing and not only
trying to build the good to empower
people to give them more people a voice
but in everything that we do we're
working to make sure that those tools
can't be misused and I think that's an
important lesson and we were focused on
it before but but not enough given the
importance of what we're doing in the
world and I think that's something that
we're going to come out of this episode
the this the series of of challenges
that we're dealing with and this will be
baked into the DNA of the company of of
how we operate
if you want more Mark Zuckerberg check
out the marks Facebook story video that
I made on him the link is right there
next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
my friends and I wanted to use at
Harvard a directory and a way to connect
with the other people around us and